are your daughters messy like this oh i
mean if this is the case then olive's
room is the natural history
museum and frankie's room is the lube
because yes
girls are messy let's serve up some news
sunny side up in huge news for the movie
business the place that i turned you
to have a very stable job and career the
wall street journal reports that warner
brothers
will release all their 2021 movies in
theaters
but more importantly on hbo max
simultaneously
they're kicking it off with wonder woman
1984 on christmas day
and they've got 17 large ticket item
movies linwell
manuel miranda's in the heights the
star-studded dunes space
jam 2 with lebron and matrix 4.
and the movies will spend a month on hbo
max
and they'll be in theaters possibly i
think it's going to be a
let's see what happens with kovid and
movie openings but
i think what this means is not only is
this just
jaw-dropping bombshell hollywood news
but i think it's now nice to know we can
rest
for 2021 this is what will be happening
oh i love this earlier you mentioned the
piece from the new yorker comparing
dating during the pandemic to being in a
jane austen
novel well i looked into it and you're
absolutely right okay the similarities
are chilling in both of them jane austen
and dating during
pandemic the main characters lead quiet
domestic lives which is so true we're
not leaving the house
check check uh in both you regularly
inquire about the health of each other's
family members
right check check check how you sisters
and cousins how they do
i always do that and last but not least
you and for your prospective
person barely ever touch and i can speak
from experience because you know
i met somebody in january that's right
before the lockdown happened and then
our whole courtship
has been really through zoom and
facetime we would like i would order
ubereats for him and we don't have dates
cute right i love this see and i was
excited for you to be on
like this subject and talk about it
because you
found love during the pandemic i did it
was tough
you know and now i'm here in the city
we're together but i feel like it also
made it very romantic
because it wasn't just you know i think
it's great because
it will force us to go back to things
like letter writing which i don't think
there's a more romantic form of
communication
if you're trying to get a job or a
boyfriend write a letter
finance news reports cnbc
petco has filed for an initial public
offering they'll be listed as
woof on the nasdaq that's a true story
not just a cute whimsical
you know nickname petco sales are up
because of the pandemic pet owners
have obviously adopted more and more and
have created a four
billion dollar uh amount in new demand
yeah and i mean i have douglas
what do you think about that what do you
have to say to petco you look riveted
douglas
yeah i'm just excited about that well i
think it's great because people have
been adopting a lot of new pets and
that's like four percent of pets are up
so it's like four billion dollars like
you said in the market because people
are spending on
on their their babies and i love this
today
reports a mom noticed her daughter's
dirty sock on the bathroom floor for
over a week
so she put up a museum placard next to
it writing
the forgotten sock mixed media on loan
from the collection of the artist
hilarious i mean this is so clever and
cool and then her daughter
hit back with an and enhanced the
exhibit
by introducing a tiny pedestal yeah mom
i see you and i'll one-up you with a
pedestal
i just love this so much are your are
your daughters messy like this
oh i mean if this is the case then
olive's room is the natural history
museum and frankie's from the because
yes
girls are messy chess
a game that's over 1 500 years old
is 2020's biggest hit because nbc news
reports that chessboards are selling out
everywhere
sales are up get this number 87
wow after the success of netflix's the
queen's gambit
and the fact that they have so many
people obviously at home
this is the perfect potent cocktail yeah
it's always been too complicated for me
i'm going to stick to checkers
okay that's right checkers i'll play
checkers with you
done
you